hallo leute ich mache mal kari antwortet
von meinem handy an verschiedenen
locations und bei mir ist heute ein
pendler erinnert euch ein kalender von
easy german acapella hat nämlich gefragt
in berlin was die leute in deutschland
lieben und jetzt hilft er mir diese kari
antwortet episode zu beantworten kann
jemand mir sagen warum so viele leute
ausnahmen über durchsprechen ich komme
aus hongkong
deshalb habe ich keine ahnung warum
deutsch auch ein meistgesprochenen
sprachen an einem afrikanische land ist
schreibt mandy i
und dazu passt die frage von keren
charakteren heiklen mir fragt gibt es
eine große gruppe von deutschen die in
namibia von also es gibt auch eine große
gruppe von deutscher hier in namibia
aber ich denke dass es war auch von von
von dem gelernten kolonialismus
geblieben
die sind hier geblieben und dann war so
viele kinder auch davon geboren und ja
die maschen
die fand noch mehr schöne musik blieben
so also dies gab die kolonialzeit wie
war nicht so schön aber heute was ich
interessant finde als deutsch als ich
zum beispiel zur essener nach namibia
kommen wenn habe ich gedacht so alle
leute hassen hier die deutschen also
dort die deutsche gruppe hier in der nie
wer also da gibt es natürlich auch
einige sind ein bisschen
aber ganz viele leute sie sprechen immer
noch deutsch
wir haben auch noch deutsch in die
schule es gibt deutsch ganz viel in der
schule und das ist spannend weil es ist
einfach heute eine minorität die rache
so genau es viele andere sprache namibia
gibt ohne sind gar nicht so viele leute
sind nur 30.000 leute es ist eine kleine
gruppe am pool und und jetzt ist frage
nummer zeit lassen
hallo kari hier eine frage für dich
deiner meinung nach wie sollte man eine
reise nach namibia planen gibt es
bestimmte orte die man unbedingt sehen
sollte wie erlebt man am besten die
natur ist sein führung nötig was wie ein
sprachen verwendet ihr am meisten um
herzukommen und so da kann ich sofort
einen tipp geben nämlich zur frage wie
sollte man eine reise nach new york
fahren gar nicht am besten kommt ihr
einfach mal an nervlich nach windhoek
und dann hört noch bender nach kapelle
oder du gehst einfach in hostels und
cooles wasser wie hier
er ist es das chamäleon hostel um uns
herum da kann ich ruhig mal werbung
machen denn wir sind schon seit vielen
jahren immer gast er kam einfach sich
mal einstecken
man kann einfach leute an der bar kennen
lernen oder kinder anrufen und mit dem
turm aber also was wirklich cool
das gibt es ja nicht in allen
afrikanischen ländern ist dass man
sind einfach ein auto mieten kann
losfahren also was schlecht ist es gibt
nicht so viele öffentliche verkehr also
man kommt nicht überall so einfach
hinten liegen die man also man muss am
besten ein auto mieten und dann sollte
unbedingt aber das ist so weit weg
es gibt nicht so im ganzen jahr man kann
nur da so ich denke also im juni und so
ich sehe für zwei monate gehen dahin so
und auf jeden fall gerade megageil und
war mein lieblings gegen das spitz köpfe
und erzgebirge immobilien sensi das
finde ich auch wie viel cool sehr nice
sprach ein führer ist nicht nötig ganz
einfach ein tourguide eingeschriebenen
drucker oder scanner mit ich bin immer
und sprachen verwendet namibia im
englisch englisch eigentlich risse
antonia aus koblenz aus dem garten ja
warum deutsche ziemlich wenig deutsche
musik sondern nur ein englische oder
amerikanische musiker ich möchte deutsch
lernen indem ich deutsch musik höre
aber es gibt nur alte musik die auf
deutsch gesungen werden und das stimmt
nicht weil es gibt eigentlich viel viel
cooler so deutsche musiker und da einer
von meinen lieblingen sind so sido ja
sie da ist einer von meinen lieblings
matches das hat mich am 765 hat das
gefahr
oder aber es stimmt nicht es gibt sehr
viel musik auf deutsch hast du notfalls
geguckt ich habe meine ganze liste
gemacht
sido ich habe meinen culcha candela da
reich kennt materie jan delay
was sind madsen fettes brot beatsteaks
thies ullmann kaspar olli schulz clueso
anderen my country zu empfehlen dass
blums okay das sind jetzt nochmals von
chessbase auch einer von meinen war
wirklich hab so lieblings ja weil er
wirklich so guten musik und seine texte
sind so der schritt der schweiz aber
seine texte hat so eine eine meinung in
einer bedeutungen so dass das lieblich
an seine musik-karriere frage ja du
kriegst auch in seinem hass kommentaren
ja leider interessanterweise im nie
aber immer dann wenn du was mit
flüchtlingen großes thema weil ich
dachte ich lest euch mal ein vor damit
ihr seht was wir so viel kommentar
kriegen dieser kommentar ist von
geeinten deutschland was für ein
populistischer manipulativer scheißdreck
wollte mir ernsthaft erzählen es sei
zufall dass keine einzige negative oder
zumindest kritische meinung zum multi
kulti waren auftaucht ausgerechnet
solche links versifften politisch
korrekten - sehen wie ihr wollt
ausländern die deutsche sprache und
kultur näher bringen das ich nicht lache
ihr wisst doch nicht mal was kultur
bedeutet und er weiß bestimmt rhein zum
erlernen der sprache markise german der
erlag der name allein ist schon
lächerlich sehr hilfreich sein da macht
ihr auch echt eine gute arbeit das muss
ich zugeben es war ein lob aber dieses
portal zur politischen stimmung und
meinungsmacher zu missbrauchen
welche darüber hinaus in hohem maße
volks schädigend ist entspricht
unterstem niveau und afrika
verboten also ich sag dazu base volk und
ich bin was das heißt volks schädigen so
hier eine aufgabe für pendler du dein
bestes diese akzente nachzuahmen
schreibt justin mitchell haus denn wir
haben schon viele fragen dem antwort
also aus dem möchte dass wir jetzt
akzente nachmachen amerikanische
russisch-britischen französisch russisch
kann ich eigentlich gut meint aber
amerikanisch nicht so meine wirklich so
ein bisschen kann ich es ganz einfach es
ist kalt musst einfach nur das heraus
sprechen wie ein amerikaner
die kunden mein russisch kann ich auf
englisch
das hast du sehr gut gemacht vierteln
dank und jetzt bitte ich bring dich um
wenn er das kind
ein bisschen schwierig den kitas größe
sich ist ein bisschen schwierig zu
sprechen ich kann das gar nicht so und
diese frage
die gebe ich mal an dich weiter capella
ducale ich möchte wissen was deine
lieblings sprachen sind aber den german
dass jeder deutsche findet deutsch ist
mein also ich würde sagen also deutsch
nicht mal auch so spanisch spanne ich
bin ja dass es pa ñol es pa ñol weil ich
bin sehr romantisch riskieren will ich
mal lernen ich kenne nur ein wort auf
rissig und er als sie nicht ein gutes
forscher sind sich aber alle blu tibia
ha ri son all unseren traum also deutsch
spanisch und ich würde sagen die
norwegisch meine lieblings sprache ist
ramona hacker konnten sie des na ja ja
ja er hat diese reihe hat ist eine
sprache sie eine der ursprünglichsten
sprachen der welt die hier gesprochen
wird
und diese es gibt vier klick laut und
die sind eigentlich will man die nicht
als kind gelernt hat unmöglich zu lernen
ja ich kenne ein paar deutsche die es
machen aber die meisten können das nicht
wenn diese kopie palm ist eine
fortsetzung deine haare weil ja die
allerletzte frage kommen von kiwi die
vor
tvb wie die vor sagt aber wann wird der
erste stammtisch in berlin stattfinden
jaja karikari ich habe eine frage wann
wird der erste stammtisch in berlin
stattfinden ich habe einen
videokommentar von euch gesehen dass ein
stammtisch organisiert wird um eine
gelegenheit zum deutsch lernen
anzubieten
ich freue mich schon drauf nette leute
und dich natürlich kennen zu lernen denn
ich bin jetzt ganz ein bisschen bedingt
ein stammt ja nie wie bdv ist ein
gedanke kiwi das uns immer was ich
gesagt habe ich das vergessen haben
harry ja also ich habe jetzt mal im
kalender geguckt mache einfach mal den
13 april da treffen uns alle
alle easyjet fans die in berlin wohnen
die in berlin
wir treffen uns alle außer cup ende des
jahres wird da sein wenn wird da sein
gitarrist peter du bist auch eingeladen
explosive einnahmen peter durch hoch
soll er leben an der decke kleben
runterfallen arsch auf knallen oder so
später peter muß auch kommen am 13 april
in berlin wahrscheinlich im biergarten
aber ich würde sagen wir halten euch
nochmal auf dem laufenden
auf facebook 13 april save the date der
isi german stammtisch für alle leute die
einsam sind in berlin
also ich hab noch einen shutout für eine
gute freunde guter freund von mir kam
aus ecommerce jetzt in bremen ja du
kennen sie auch antonia ja sagt dass ich
ein shoutout bremen nach bremen
danke dass du warst ein weiteres video
maybe a cappella folgt bald selbst
gespannt und wir sind euch schöne grüße
aus windhoek mit einem schönen
sonnenuntergang kann man da hinter
palmen auch ist das ja bei den winter